Okay, let's see how we do this. The operator that we're going to do during the reduce is max.
So 2 max 1. Which one's bigger? Two. Four max 3. Which one's bigger? Four.
Two max 4. Which one's bigger? Four. We're done with the reduce.
So now we begin the downsweep. Remember, we start with the identity element here.
And then we're going to apply the downsweep operator.
In this case, we're doing a downsweep with a max.
So, we will copy to the left, just as in the sum example.
And we will apply max to each, each of the pairs of elements to create the output to its right.
So right now we're running our downsweep operator on this 2 and this 0, okay?
We copy the 0 over. And now we run max on 2 and 0 and get 2, okay?
Now, we'll drag down these intermediate values here.
So, we'll copy this to the left, and then 2 max 0, gives us 2.
We'll copy to the left, and then 2 max 4 gives us 4, and then we'll complete.
Note that the output on any particular element is equal to
the maximum value we've seen up to, but not including this element.
The max value we see here is 4, which is the max value of each element we've seen up to this point.